absolutely lovely to see you here at
London Film and Comic Con today how are
you enjoying the event I'm having the
important thing is how are all these
thousands of nice people enjoying it and
they seem to be so that's the important
thing I enjoy it if the customers are
happy now of course obviously I'm sure
lots of people are asking you about your
time as the doctor
what were your favorite memories from
your time in the TARDIS just doing it
for three years I was the doctor and
that was delightful I would say hello to
people and they say hello back it was a
rare privilege
how would you characterize your doctor
in comparison to the many doctors you've
seen over the years oh I wouldn't dare
characterize my doctor at all I let
others do that comparisons are obvious
all I did was turn up and do what I
thought was right for my doctor I let
other people decide on what those
characteristics were why do you think
Doctor Who is still going strong soap
opera is Venus fiftieth anniversary year
it's still going because it's very good
it hit the ground running at the right
time it's all about timing you could
have started that program five years
early or five years later and it might
have disappeared but it just caught on
at a time when space travel was of
interest science fiction itself was not
highly regarded by the media at that
time but it snuck in the back door
somehow
and then once they did that first
regeneration then
the precedent was set and it was off I
think Matt Smith the current doctor is
fantastic I'm loving watching him it's
sad to see him go as well as it of
course we always have to lose a doctor
to get a new doctor in of course there's
loads of speculation out there now about
who should be the new doctor and who it
might be who do you think would be good
or what kind of doctors it would be good
for the 21st century well leaving aside
the controversy about whether it should
be female or not and I happen to believe
there's absolutely no reason why it
shouldn't be female I mean if the doctor
has 12 incarnations surely he must be in
touch with his feminine side to a
certain extent but I think the most
appropriate person to play the new
doctor is someone like Matt Smith that
we'd never heard of before you make this
all go guess that's the doctor and
that's the job that the producers having
which they did so well last time so we
have to assume they will do well next
time what would you like to say to your
fans out there who are watching this
interview well those fans are in town
you're all remarkable and the fact that
I'm sitting here signing autographs for
people who
weren't even born when I pray the doctor
is a testament to the success of the
program and the fans are just brilliant
all of them
you